how's it goin breasts my name is Pierre
dapat unfortunately I have some bad news
there's no way I'm going to be able to
post any videos this week something just
came up and I got to go but hey that's
how it is and I have ninokuni recorded
for seven days however and it's an
amazing game of loving it
and I think you bros are gonna love it
too so I'm going to post one of those
each day this week and I can't post
anything else so if you you know if I
see people complaining about worse the
scary videos and where's Conker's Bad
Fur Day and where is this and that
needeth not and I'm just gonna pause it
and then I'm just gonna come back next
Monday when when I'm back pretty much
and I'll be back then otherwise you can
enjoy this ninokuni and I that's what I
hope at least because yeah anyway thanks
for being sporty bros I'm gonna miss you
say awesome ma in the previous episode
[Music]
Singapore Eduardo Chitina Yakuza Kagari
huh all right
Ramos Sakai ninokuni tio Ghana in o Kuhn
8b o Meno who canto Thomas EO que usted
no ah ninokuni no kensa re shiozawa to
you AG Ana Odysseus ami no mado a bony
katakana s er o matic irani abre yeah
see nota magnetos de cámara read okay
you are - muchas Oregon tetra we have to
save her mouth I want to do that I wanna
do that
we're going to ninokuni thousand-dollar
best my name is welcome back to me the
code part 3 we just relive the Lion King
scene again and yeah we just went
through the [ __ ] portal thing a
little bit GK yeah and we have a stick
and a buck and a doll that talks with a
nice parenting I want that piercing oh
my god
the weird thing is yo a c'mere thinkin o
ciock a nomadic urea nada Teemo sasazuka
segundo año más aquí no ah y know see
Cara Maria ara
re Co sunny no catty note I see ya come
to step mmm mmm mmm oh snap
oh my god it's hideous huh I get the
feeling we gonna do our first battle man
you know you must couple us out here me
Timmy what's up the cookie maja Maya oh
I'm gonna kill that another thing boy
boom Oh to the arrow so it's a tote idea
oh yeah yeah do it your way
are you tapping it [ __ ] come on main
all right so we can use spells in [ __ ]
now I whoa that's like I'm actually
curious what the [ __ ] how you actually
play in this game
extra attack well that was difficult
don't fret olive I let your old pal
dreamy talk you through the basic of the
battle first I'll take a look at the
green house health I'm not an idiot blue
helmets magic points all right don't
worry about Matty for now let's talk
about B C's first shall we
ruff what's up ruff you can see lots of
information about them up there on the
right there's useful a the red gosh
right Jesus [ __ ] Christ
uh-huh uh-huh whoa
I am attacking him but I think I'd
actually tidy
or should I say nice that's what you say
when you find an enemy's weak spot all
right
what is this a glim enemies drop them in
the heat of battle
glim green gleams like that one you just
grabbed resort okay cool
balloons gives your mana okay all right
cool it's pretty [ __ ] straightforward
but I like it anyway I was worried about
the gameplay being oh [ __ ] I got a
glimpse what's up what you gonna do ruff
you're in my town now [ __ ] let's try
to defend just for the heck of it I
blocked with my butt let's go that rhyme
attack I thought we'd use spells and
[ __ ] and I just hit him with a stick
then poor little rough alright turn in
it whoa for XP
I'm almost level two [ __ ] what's up
booty ba sutiya I didn't die
Jeepers Creepers condo pcs awesome bye
bye na evening Arriba ahh
look we're [ __ ] I wound up co t need
any but I already have one
yeah we are not Korea Koro silicon
sorry y ec te la mujer oh you're se que
hacer lo mejor EO Cunha King Tiger gate
wat sky taco uncle Joey maha was on
obsidium week to talk Acharya sir Evo
Todaro
us a king guru no Coco chuckling are so
no Kuni Otunga Oh guitar stops great Oh
cally no voter karma say alright we're
gonna get a new one let Sun on each oh
no no no no ya know cassia Yosef tango
na ya be no mado see Chavo garage Atty
oh really mess betcha Boehm aho Thiago
token DJ Scott ammonia new okay
Nina's a boa sorte ma hosted [ __ ]
love is piercing son an acquaintance or
a cotton Indian is a little arrow yeah
throw my wood
I wonder how long it's gonna take until
we see someone on the internet post
himself with a piercing like that
oh sorry no yokogao cry trauma die
Hazara kokoro no achieve over a mu k
gonna be Tony Sharkey's mom let's go
brokenhearted so it did three tiny turns
them into salvo hilarity no Kagura be
Tony not Arya to notice in dono Calaca
run Joe tides also Leone giving an eye
in Aptos my hmm Amina Chavo so learned
are a son annoy you Rosanna yo-yo say no
cheating Oh noona raoji correct ARMA
Jerome I love you next time oh my Itachi
abode hacer cosas beaucoup gotcha bow I
believe in you buy you are the PR
Hodgenville I I mean on my home which
gets you eat [ __ ] up here cut out oh my
a job or social home time taken on my
home on on the up Dana it sounds my
neighbors
alright we're gonna learn medic breath
how about that your mama hold up see
guys your target Lorenza Meza Suba
: arrow go granny ding-dong Dali go
there alright
we actually get to play yay I know a
lotta brothers have been saying Oh James
shock because I can you never play but
any beautiful holy boy ah it's good to
be back our well that's really riddled
with math says if one of the spots from
you you'll see a exclamation point pop
up over its head and it'll charge when
it gets touching that okay if you run
out of HP need you okay
here's a tiny little technique for you
if you sneak up behind monitors without
noticing you can get the first set in
giving you the alright let's go that's
cool
another thing is it works the other way
around - okay
oh yeah it's just a little something
instead I got a gift from Lord
hi Ally daughter fares three levels of
white bread my god ah thanks what I do
with this you have to match one father
and when you feel a bit ropey and you'll
be right as rain in no time man
but the weather cannot live by bread
alone alibi and it's a proper one and
all and that nobly thing in your head is
doing my flippin headed see that big
castle to the north where yeah that it
is that's the ding Donnell ok I
recommend is there a little bit away ok
so we're gonna go there and hopefully
we'll actually get to oh [ __ ] it saves
me I want to try a little battling god
damn this game is really beautiful even
like this that's really cool all right
let's try an escape on our roughing now
[ __ ] rough face beautiful soundtrack
beautiful graphics I love it it's pretty
pretty cool alright let's sneak up on
this [ __ ] oh no blam bang [ __ ] it saw
me a by tender it's a gay unicorn with a
buck - unicorn alright
ah [ __ ] - [ __ ] oh you missed attacking
woah it's dangerous
what's provision I don't need that now
attack yeah yeah what's that
[Music]
they're dead
level 2 1 gold I'm rich
Oliver reach level 2 cool
good job Oliver all right well one more
battle and then we go to the castle how
about I just add some video I can't
actually hear you but I'm gonna get sim
you said it sounded good good not shut
plan bang
Bob Lana say ahh ahh
I've gotta be sneaky
oh it's a pinata Oh shet Gambetta [ __ ]
I missed me attack
slap that [ __ ] with the wand
wow that did a lot of damage
yay what that what that with that
[Music]
alright forgo that pitch after was
[ __ ] loaded one more envoy you said
one more I saw a glimpse in your eyes
let's attack this [ __ ] the music is
really awesome
Ruud Reiner socks it's like a dinosaur
and a rhinoceros come at me bro
come at me bro hi I didn't know you
could have range attacks [ __ ] nice
hahahaha so Japanese what is he doing in
the background anyway huh alright let's
see how much we got from that one only
two gold I got the feelin wait oh
there's like glitter up here I wanna
check that out
um can I go here oh I didn't say me I
didn't say me
no no oh they run forwards straight when
they see I want to check this out what
is this a bunch of booster shots it's
that one it's I'd like for to get drunk
or something oh look at that
alright well we're going to the castle
you can call him your Ted snap jeez I
see your tits shaking it's just kind of
crazy
what Oh knickers there's something I
forgot to tell you well I'd miss a
drippy and my oil you can use to change
your viewpoint full of [ __ ]
you got me [ __ ] [ __ ] if you
haven't notice I
like oh no way before I was playing like
there's no no even though I remember
when I didn't need 10 to 64 controller
the first time I was a kid and I had no
idea how to hold and you were like what
the [ __ ] is this how did it I don't even
know
well he looks drunk always brokenhearted
no moon Bhawan okay grab it or lottery
Oh Anna Kegel a veto Monomoy T de Italia
yeah no keg arrivederci no kokoro no mor
tamaño de joder move o no se lo hace
esto toes Tino Honda yo Chino Hoppus I
am NOT in your team up to yellow cow
Bonilla jabbawockee una hum kimono toga
Shivan adopt a kid named Roberto stick
it again okay gotta go instead how the
hotel uh-huh tapirs maharaja wanna go go
can you hide in are you we can teleport
then you'd better cure him main to
Charlie boy it's time to mend your first
broken heart mend it but how do I do
that I get the feeling he's gonna tell
me well you can't do it just yet shut
there's a couple of things we need to
deliver but I put on but I know I'm an
old man who just wanna pop we need to
see a weather and a half an old man and
all my the old man ain't it lives in the
wood to the north over here proper deed
and deeply dark it is that's why they
call it the deep dark wood but it makes
sense I guess
I guess so go to the deep dark wood and
meet the old man in the wood
go to the darker to meet good god good
this guy doesn't look so broken Harlan
it looks pretty badass so that one is
not broken harder than then maybe just
like this is what I do when I get up for
golf the first swing you see doing in
the background go to the deep dark wood
meet old man in the woods go to the deep
dark wood meet the old man in the
woodwork go to the deep-pocketed we take
old man in the wood will TP
I tried ding dong Dell [ __ ] awesome
names gonna tell everything alright I
was in the north right let's check our
map I can't open my map Ellis all right
whoa it's so far which rod should we
take from here browse I'm not sure
because we need to plan it properly it's
a lake of the day we might run into some
danger I'd say we just follow here
yeah kreitzman so beautiful this game I
still I still think journeys a little
prettier not I think about it but it's a
lot shorter than and you got you he
slaps it on but wow that guy is awesome
that is me if I were a Pokemon I mean I
run us attack miss bet you don't miss
I'm running alone health hey
all right let's kill him and then we'll
use the brand or whatever yeah they're
dead
their daughter uh-huh
yes pills needs to figure out how to
open the bag
oh there it is I didn't see my
microphone was covering all right here
we go wow it really gives you full
health
uh-huh sorry about this chat i am esmi
let's fight this one guy Simon is it
bunny let's kill the bunny I don't think
that was a badass what that [ __ ] that
he's suckin his own deck yeah what that
[ __ ]
alright attack bang hey what's up what's
up - nostril pick me up
okay well batting that is nice
well I'm glad we actually get to finally
play the game you know but the
soundtrack don't even get me started the
subtype Joe
hi-c ah she is that anything this is a
[ __ ] genius I mean I'm a genius
turbine oh no it's another pajota
machina Archie gotta all look asses back
now it's a chance to fight no how do you
miss heavies right there seriously
what's up a killing poor animals they
never dropped the things I'm a little
bit disappointed at that I hope it's
gonna happen more in the future as you
can actually be like run around and [ __ ]
and then couchette that cave looks cold
should we go there now we can't I'll
shut that rhinoceros look at that pimp
over here let's fight him pam-pam battle
again whoa here's a pen
look at that guy whoa he sucks ha ha ha
ha I kill that [ __ ] why are you
breathing out that was easy
come on don't even don't even try to
pretend that was difficult ya-da-da-da
oh it's a bridge chair so we don't have
to cross the water cool huh we got a
difficult one but we can sneak up on him
I snack and sneak up on him just like
Snooki sneak up on a it's a bartender
Yash gone bad off hi
not [ __ ] you messed you suck man I'm not
attack Nima's Publio that's what's up
oh yes I got it
level up what's that level up what's up
made my back but uh but up but up wait
my button oh it's a game on what's up I
fight you something wrong with fighting
gay I mean being gay a sleeper foul
machina asleep a foul drowsy drops
oh shut he is rainbow attack of course
nice nice pitch
oh thank god I thank God that gave
Pokemon there and kill me
look I wouldn't look bad in my
reputation pits dead by gay Pokemon well
I'm sorry but I want to check out this
castle or whether I [ __ ] it how do I
get up here how does one it doesn't have
entrance for now I'm going back to you
rainbow castle look at that oh well
we're going in here breasts to delete
dark woods to deep dark woods to deep
dark woods to the deep dark woods girl
duck duck would put it on the finish
here better than Skrillex girl sorry
about that
look at that that's a waste um that's
theirs either useful white stone I can
already guess whether this gotta be it's
so annoying when they have to let them
explain it like I don't know a store and
record your adventure cell 5 and while
places like forest and so on you can
just plunk yourself in the nerves
rotting right
no but why not why not he says give me
strength money because they're craving
with horrible busy ain't it they are
that sounds kinda scary
we'll get you sweet money just remember
you can't go recording your progress in
our own way
allow me to explain little more touch
away stone and your health America I
will okay [ __ ] you okay
look at that
all right so you get your health full
and you get save easy yawning in the
background are you not entertained yet
so you see you enter from that hole
that's kind of cool
that's kind of cool that's kind of neat
oh that's kind of neat oh I like this
uh-huh oh look pretty flower look at
that what happens if I go over here I'm
sorry just curious
mmm pretty flowers what's up oh can I
swim nope
how would I jump on the stone but this
is me I'm just time effectively
oh come on your vests and now he's gonna
look up in the wizard is there or the
castle no no no but you oh well what a
surprise
oh it's a tree that was actually
surprising it's a [ __ ] duck shrink
what the [ __ ] that is surprising your
leaf eNOS go
well she not know yoga I don't happiness
Kuniko single asana una notte dumb Nani
yo I wrote Skaro a cos theta back
slightly oh my god it's beautiful
Georgia yes thumbnail right there Donny
right more customers kosuna cool so
Renault okay the kingdom sceeto kokoro
no more chili chic oh it's completely
mental a child who I am you and you
arrived at them darkness Moscow boy hi
Hitachi Yamoto Takayama's wha no
hahaha the best laugh ever
who are you callin back and I yeah it's
[ __ ] fake are Carlo Castillo
yay Casey so no Marisa Nakano emoji oh
do Nico Cinnabon are now much Oh Phil
what's wrong
what flew to this task I don't wanna go
you are a Telugu - tell me okay I get
all my imagine no - gotta lose it with
our walk imagine what's our familiars
imagine imagine an could you do a given
no code it's like a faucet a since you
are really so they got emails into you
okay go meet you
wow this sounds awesome pants pants
event oh my no imagine you hit something
when I walked you them up
Oh dick you cannot directly young
Combusken arrow ah magic come on Flo he
write it for the heroes in Omaha Scotty
me but mr. drippy there is no spell rune
firm familiar hair you what the boys
correct
look at his wizard companion it would
seem that I'm a duck that is is missing
more than a few of his pages really
nickers so catfish oh I am not as
powerless as all of that young man
Oliver was it let me see now
from familiar is a gift from me to you
young Oliver you stupid [ __ ] oh why did
I come from
that was quite a handy thing from her
for a duck at least
whoa we got a new spell Broyles we've
got a new spell Shh
we got a new spell brooch we got a new
spell we're gonna check it out in the
next episode kind of paws hair get a
pause hair like if it if you enjoyed I'm
glad I get to play it's fun I love it
salesmen
[Music]